[Music]
president obama answered questions live
on twitter this was a big deal and i was
checking it out i saw some of the
responses and now that the election is
over I'm getting the impression
President Obama it's getting a little
cocky working to win public support for
his tax and spending proposals President
Obama answered fiscal cliff questions on
Twitter Monday one Twitter follower
asked why won't keeping tax rates low
across the board encourage more hires
and therefore more tax revenue the
president replied high-end tax cuts
would cost almost one trillion dollars
while extending middle-class cuts will
boost growth another Twitter follower
wrote how will you stop us from going
over the fiscal cliff and will it
involve significant deficit reduction to
which the president replied wait I
thought Twitter was supposed to be fun
where are all the crazy PAC videos at
hashtag boring hash tag Twitter fail and
a third follower asked how long will it
take you to fix the economy and lower
unemployment the president answered way
too long obviously LOL but guess what I
got reelected anyway you got very oh for
four more sweet ones
hashtag Sukkot
confident
you